another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do at the foundation telling  new researchers that you can tame  scp-682 with a rolled-up newspaper and a  tummy rub when you've been alive for as  long as dr bright with the knowledge of  eternity stretching out before you you  can watch every movie and show play  every game and read every book that's  why dr bright sometimes resorts to more  esoteric methods of amusement such as  feeding the newbies little white lies  about anomalies like telling them  scp-682 can be tamed with a rolled up  newspaper and tummy rubs like a  misbehaving puppy which must have seemed  really funny until six new researchers  got devoured and considering what a  nightmare employee turnaround is at the  scp foundation already losing employees  for a reason this stupid really didn't  sit well with the 05 council